The 5th of May is traditionally known as Tango no Sekku.
It's a day to pray for the healthy growth of boys.
In households across Japan, parents display suits of armor...
...and dolls modeled after legendary warriors,...
...wishing that their sons will be strong.
The celebration of Tango no Sekku is incomplete...
...without carp-shaped streamers known as koinobori.
Koinobori come in many sizes.
There are small ones only a few dozen centimeters long,...
...and also large ones over ten meters long.
Tango no Sekku celebrated on May the 5th involves many traditions and customs.
They reflect not just a wish for the healthy development of boys,...
...but also Japanese people's attentiveness to seasonal changes.